hi in this video we'll talk about
actin microfilaments so microfilaments
are usually
seven nanometer in diameter and they're
made up of
actin proteins so if we look at a cell
generally we would find these actin
proteins or actin microfilaments
in the periphery of the cell or the
cortex of the cell and literally they
are present in any kind of eukaryotic
cells so they are generally situated in
the periphery
and microfilaments are flexible and
relatively strong in nature they're
resisting
buckling of the cell structure
by kind of countering piconewton forces
that are applied on the cell due to
mechanical damage or mechanical stress
so they are a important component of the
cytoskeletal system of a cell
now they can be found in different
locations
like they can be found in microvilli
adhesion bills cell cortex contractile
rings
phylopodial lamellapodia cell cortex or
even in the stress
fiber so their organization could be
very different depending upon the places
they are found
and they are broadly distributed in
different locations in epithelials and
different cell types
now microfilaments their function
includes cell motility so they are
really involved
in cellular movement there take an
important role in cytoskenesis
especially pinching off two cells and
separating two cells
and this is done by a actomyosin ring
contraction mechanism
lastly change in shell cell shape
is also modulated by microfilaments
so let us look at the microfilament
structure their assembly kinetics and
the stability
in details so each component
of the micro filament is known as
globular actin
indeed actin can be there in two formats
in a soluble
globular actin format or in a
filamentous actin format so filamentous
actin
format is basically a polymer of
globular actin
assembled in a specific way now each
actin molecule contains a mg2 plus ion
and a atp binding cleft
so atp hydrolysis is important for actin
polymerization
so let us look at the structure of
globular actin to understand
its functionality in details so if you
look at the
actin structure there are four
subdomains
now there is an important region in the
actin structure which is the atp binding
cleft which binds to the atp
and in the atp binding configuration
they could be polymerized or added up
into the existing
uh microfilament so atp binding
is very important for actin assembly
other than that there is a magnesium two
plus ion which
helps in polymerization as well now each
microfilament
is made up of two helical intercollected
strand of
subunits now for polymerization it is
necessary atp gets
converted to adp so atp
adp is converted to atp and
exchanged this exchange is important for
it to be recruited into the
growing strand of microfilament
so here is quite a lot of globular actin
and this globular actin has specific
structural features
it has a barbed end and a pointed end
now let us look at what happens when the
nucleation of actin takes place
so the nucleation of actin is kind of a
spontaneous process
few acting monomers or globular actins
assemble together to form a nucleus
on top of which the subunits can be
assembled
one end is known as barbed end and other
end is known as
pointed end the rate of addition is way
more
in the burning in contrast to the
pointed end
so if you look at the polymerization you
can understand there are
it's a polar kind of structure which has
one minus
end and another is plus end so in the
plus end
atp bound g acting gets recruited
and in the minus end adp bound g acting
gets dissociated
so atp bound g acting recruitment is
important for the polymerization step
now there would be certain situation
where the rate of
addition would be kind of equalized
to the rate of dissociation in an in
vitro settings
and this situation is known as
treadmilling
where the minus end has concentration
just below the critical concentration
whereas the plus end has a concentration
above the critical concentration let me
tell you that critical concentration
is a particular concentration range
which is crucial
for the polymerization of the
actin filaments so this phenomena is
known as
treadmilling where it is
broken down from one end and polymerized
in the other end and the rate is kind of
equal as if it looks like the rotating
treadmill now let us look at a cell and
try to understand
that actin it's not necessary for acting
to be in a
bundle format so obviously acting could
be in a branched format
known as actin network obviously actin
can be found as acting bundles
also there could be contractile acting
bundles found in a cell
which is migrating and all of the
different specification of actin is
important for the cellular function
specially think about
a cell which is migrating all of these
networks would be
crucial for them to migrate now let us
talk about few proteins which help in
this polymerization process
most important of them is known as
forming
formins are actually group of protein
that are involved in polymerization of
actin
and they associate with the fast growing
end or barbed end
also forming help in the nucleation
process and thereby forming
or polymerizing the actin microfilament
there is another protein known as arp23
it has a branching function
it can bind to an existing actin
microfilament
and initiate a new branch there so a
branch point is initiated by these
complexes
now they really help in stability of the
actin
filament as well but there are dedicated
proteins
which kind of cross-link actin such as
passing
fibrine alpha-catenine and spectrine
which governs acting networks are stable
or
active networks don't dissociate so
rapidly so these proteins are very
important for maintain
for the maintenance of the rigidity of
the cell
or also the structure of the acting
networks
other than that there are proteins such
as profiling which
kind of work like a atp exchange factor
so it exchange atp instead of
adp and it would help the recruitment
into the barbed end other than that
there is
cofilin which can bind to the
filamentous actin and can sever the
actin filament
so about these proteins which can really
uh
stabilize or destabilize actin filament
association
we would learn about them in a different
video but it's not necessary
that these factors which would help the
stability of actin filament
is a protein there are many other
factors such as spalloiding which can
bind and help to stabilize the actin
filament
following was initially isolated
from a death cap mushroom now there are
other protein
and other components such as electron
cooling which prevents the subunit
from binding to each other and forming
the chain so there are
chemical agents which can also help
or they can dissociate the actin
filament so i hope you enjoyed this
video but just to summarize
we looked at subcellular localization of
microfilaments
assembly kinetics of the actin
microfilament
and regulation of the microfilament
assembly what are the proteins what are
the other factors that
govern the stability and instability of
these structures we have looked at them
so guys please don't forget to like
share and subscribe
and do join my course in an academy
which is india's biggest learning
platform right now
and e-learning is promoted here if you
want to join use my code ep10 to get a
10
discount thank you